today we are going to play Starfield
through this Samsung Neo Q LED
television look at the size of this
thing I think it's the largest flat
screen I've ever seen it's 85 in I don't
believe you in fact let's test how big
this is right now I'm bringing in right
now just to test this a six foot party
sub look at that it is even longer than
a 6 foot party sub gentlemen can you
come take it now these are union guys so
they're going to devour this in second
you should see the box that came in it's
I want to see the box that came in yeah
okay where's the box I'll get it usually
I don't talk a lot about boxes but check
out the box that the this Samsung TV
comes in look at this thing it's massive
I plan to be buried in this box yes
along with friends and loved ones like
the Egyptian pharaohs guys could you
take this away please Mr R I bet you
already ate that sandwich didn't
you yes
okay man there they go so Starfield uh
is a an epic open world RPG set in the
future uh a a giant tail spanning uh
countless light years across the settled
systems uh you're you're a miner and
you're you're mining some minerals and
you come across this weird piece of
metal touch it you see lights and music
and it turns out it's this artifact
group called constellation which is kind
of a rag tag group of dou people from
there any way we could ever skip past
this part and start playing the game and
then you say go grab shiny thing and
then we learn as we go because these
Tales you tell I swear to God my heart
stopped four times while you were
talking okay well and I'm sure it's a
great game but you going yeah then
xandor comes but beware the skugal do
beware various systems merging with
other forces black holes merging with
other holes we don't need that all right
okay forehead yeah let's go crazy on the
forehead and see what
happens I like this guy this guy can
break through an iceberg with his head
that's great we're going to get sued by
the estate of Dolph lungren and he's
still
alive very rare that the estate goes
after you when the guy's still alive if
you press y you have a jetpack so you
could press Y and then press it again
and you could press it so you double
jump press it yeah there you go you can
kind of do a little jump jumpy thing
there all right wait a minute what what
is it how can I get it's kind of it's
not a great jetpack this is a crappy
jetpack it will boost you 7even Ines at
a time what is this jetpack it's it's
like he's just farting
powerfully he's being propelled inches
at a time abandoned meat pack
fac system oh my God and
then and then more another one
youve got some incredible time
regardless here I've never seen anything
less cool in my
life